das ist komisch
im darmstädter meinungen das ist viel
kommentiert wurde und mit betrag es ist
viel diskutiert wurde christa 5 und
darum machte jetzt auf die sache ruhiger
einem verdiener künftig zum beispiel
götz der lukas kurs wieder gefragt wieso
habe ich mich nicht für professionelle
bezirks bis längerfristige analyse
entschieden das ist alles ein grund das
hat einfach rein wirklich zeitlichen
rahmen vom inneren reportage sprang wenn
ich da jetzt über zwei oder saniert oder
vielleicht sogar das jahr zwei jahre das
ganze war logische wahl das mega
spannend wird teil 2 aber jetzt haben
wirklich dem gold rush will und nach ab
und ich doch auch von vielen kolleginnen
wie die kartoffel hebisch oder tobias
scherbarth dass ich mich schnell
habe ich wert der welle in stürze und
nur gewusst dass mit mir macht und das
ruhiger und jetzt langfristig
analysieren das ist er nicht weiß wo man
am anfang so machen wir das weil
abbilden wo vermutlich baby viele andere
auch passiert und tennis wo nicht ein
kommentar die nachts sondern ganz viele
verschiedene kommentar betroffenheit ist
thematisch breiter reportage gesprochen
haben mit dem ganze spam mit dem bus mit
dem ganzen nicht reguliert sie und zwar
ist gott nachbar minuten reportage sind
unzählige kommentar und
welche roboter sind dir kostet wurde
weil die sind oft risse schlagwörter
programmiert wie krupp der waage bitcoin
btc und die positiven wir so nachricht
davon läuft eigentlich so diskussion
verläuft vorheriger kolportage
schön wie du das gemacht sich mit
langfristigen verstehen wer hätte zum
beispiel die xy kurve und dann sind
putzmunter
xy hat mir super cool verschrieben team
dort auf die adresse und das zeigt
einfach wir fest also das wilde westen
ist dass man versucht die lücke bis ins
ziel
mit dem spieler das man eigentlich
gehofft dass die luft auf sein bissiger
kälte dann irgendwie anfragen und die
garzeit und frieden profi trader wiener
hat vermutlich cool fällt dem den
aushilfen als ganzes lauf ganz viel
einfach so sache wo man sich fragt was
gott du einfach nicht reguliert ist also
wirklich so wilde westen pour piano
faktoren ist wald von club-boss somit
auch an die ganz klar sagen ja
einerseits die exponate also die krypto
in frenzel wo einfach wirklich neuen sci
fi fans wenn nicht sogar mehr prozent
von deiner wirklich sind also ich kann
doch als 23
cdm ganz business immer so aber die sind
relativ sag mal im flutlicht oder
größere crypto influenza sind die
relativ league sie im sinn vor 22 30
voll oder so vielleicht 20 aber jeder
größe wie es jetzt ihr mann welcher klub
torin francis sie sind und ich hatte
damals aber nicht chris im interview
gefragt was denkst du wieso ist das so
also sind einige show sollte einfach
dass man filme quasi risikobereit viel
risikobereiter sind
natürlich um macht um irgendwie hier und
das sind alles emotionales
charaktereigenschaften wo man erhält
jeder zeit darstellt macht euch gern für
der zweite teil von dem krimi zum usv
walter weiss doch messbar kommentar das
paar diskussionspunkt gar nicht gern die
wird vertieft mit euromobil cruise kann
also klar dass auch liebe antwort aber
ich glaube er hat tatsächlich besser
verteilen und und hätte ich wie ein
blick in das ganze also
nur zu verwalten also es das spiel
gefunden mit ihrer klage über die awards
ab
abseits geschossen
ich sehe das hier
kann der fuß ist eine wo selber
wahrscheinlich relativ gut rauskommt ein
gutes beispiel mit wasser gequält wenn
er eine ganze klub beleidigen oder gar
nicht versteht und so geht's eigentlich
so zwei schlüssel konzepte und anfang
april muss klar machen dass ein teil ist
das dezentral und biss sie nur im alltag
von vielen momenten schon dezentral ist
zum beispiel so ein match up gruppen
oder das heißt jede nacht auf 7 handy
demnach nötig und zweiten ist das davos
pending problem wo bitcoin einkaufs
klöster oder wohnen einkaufen kommt neu
geschrieben das klopfen ist so
unrühmlich solcher verlauf wurde ein
blog oder muss gar zum höchsten
wertungsklasse viel hat das ist ein
anfang für blüte recht gut die analogie
und nicht so bei klarer luft und das
meistens tut sehr gut die aber das ist
natürlich wie jedem modell und jedem
vergleich nimmt das hängt aber 400
stellen und ist überhaupt keine frage
offen für alle besser klar gesetzt hat
die verfolger blumen für solche klar zu
machen wo nun hiermit bitcoin mit
kryptologie pedelecs wie das
funktioniert aber ich möchte mich auch
das durchaus aber vielleicht finde und
roland hochschule fragt hätte es
überhaupt noch zukunft das ist der zug
schon abgefahren mit einer krücke war
das ist große ganze mädchen machen ja
mit zukunft große oder durch mich auch
keiner sagen aber im letzten monat das
bitcoin für eine stütze könne haufe und
damit 50 musik wert ist das ein faktor
50 oder also das hat nochmals geld für
50 musiker
ja ich glaube also was heißt für die
roland das große geld was ich immer noch
möglich ist aber das ist überall möglich
oder das regime einen glücklich macht
sie aber frage sei welches vorher schon
das geht halt humer bist du das glück
durch einen lottospieler glück durchaus
lücke aber gibt's merkmal das durch über
analytik josef in der was soll ich auf
so dass gegen den faktor 50 musik machen
das glaube ich eigentlich nicht aber so
ein faktor oder so sicher eigentlich ist
absolut in ich habe es absolut vz
absolut in denn auch ein aspekt wo es
erkannt worden ich so klimaschädlichkeit
oder mining bezirk treptow war wieso ist
das so so stattlich oder es ist
natürlich so moment geht's auf zehn
minuten geht es für davos juli findet
durch die zeigt wo gibt's moment sechs
bitcoins
und das sind zum einen aktuelle priest
330 franken also auch zwei minuten kommt
ein natürlich musik führen können es ist
klar dass natürlich daran viel mitmachen
oder 40 versucht die entrückung musik
franken als auch in unteren über zu und
wie kommt man das über den damen aber
schneller als die anderen und findet das
heißt ein
computer für sich laden oder rechnen als
der betrag und vans und elektromusik
frankreich kann jeder mitsingen computer
das auf dem computer aufstellen und so
viel strom verbrauchen da sind gerade
die drohung mit nur sie fragen können
die flucht und ja das ist natürlich viel
oder mehr führt 330 franken als ein
unterlassen computer juli sicher dass
strom und ist das fast wie immer
schädlich und das ist nicht gut sind ja
ganz finnland wo also ganz verliert wo
das mitmachen das absolut in russland
genau sekretär der big points ein ich
mache ganz genau einfach so dass nicht
mehr als trio mit musik franke hochstuhl
umziehen und auch ständige kühn hätte
das ist das wo alle macht der arbeit hin
und her macht taschen leer also bleibt
er spricht aber schon dadurch dass
trader aber dass das nicht so sinnvoll
ist also das ist einfach längerfristig
als die rosetta spaziert wird des
studios mit dem trader also ich selber
mich heimat halten einfach einmalig haus
und hebbel oder das berühmte hotel und
nicht hin und herz trader die gans zieht
das 1 2 aus sperrzeiten ist erstens
macht die psychologisch fertig oder man
sich extrem stressig rundum tool für aci
und der schlimmes gefühl ich hatte
oder weniger
nach unten zu ordnen dass phils gefühlen
machen das wie vor hart sehe was wird
passieren oder das stück sehen und das
ist doch mehr zur farce prozess als
vorhersagbar die meisten laufen triumph
verlieren relativ viel das ist auch gut
so und bei maximaler versucht mir so
schwankungen vereinzelt luft fahren da
man mehr oder weniger ganz merck kauft
oder also das ist so die ganze fonds der
spielzentrale wenn einen abstürzt und
das machen die alles versuchen dass auch
viel salz kopieren also wenn ich zum
beispiel viel geld an dich aufs eis oder
und aller zeiten wo sich stützen könnte
braucht aber eine explodiert der
natürliche look stehenden plus nach köln
gemacht und das mache so alleinige
stradinger dass das mag für viele
spannen sie aber nicht ich glaube es
haniel konzern den markt voraussagen und
darum ist wahrscheinlich beste wirkt
also die hre-krise letzten letzten endes
glaubte hält logo finden was auch
holzholen ist in der reportage ist der
unterschied zwischen
bitcoins außerdem dezentraler und
der unter anderem rückte war wohl nie
druck setzen zu lassen weil das
entwicklerteam dahinter steckt was ist
der unterschied zwischen agenda an allen
anderen klub der waage und mit freunden
also gut bekannt sind die einzige klub
zu wenig oder dezentral ist und das
entwicklerteam
stagnierenden oder mieter hätten und
müssen entwickelt werden das war bitcoin
wirklich speziell ist und wo bitcoin so
einzigartig macht ist
nicht nur das gesicht sondern eine frau
das auto china konnte um den mediziner
dass man nicht weiß wer sich und das
geht natürlich um bitcoin der aufstrich
für unabhängigkeit wie kann eine zweite
welle oder das ist der erste und der
ursprung ist irgendwie
mystische im dunkeln und dass das hatte
damals das wird keine anderem schon für
wahrscheinlich hier wird es danken wir
für marl noch für drei jahre
dann komme ich nochmal
produkten egal ob sie gut oder schlecht
aber das kommentierte mitdiskutieren das
ist super für die zukunft kommentiert
weiterhin fleißig mit und wenn er also
reckt reportage folge jetzt doch da auf
dem youtube-kanal